coding has changed in fascinating ways
because so much of coding is copying
pasting from stack Overflow and then
adjusting
which is another way of coding and I
don't want to talk down to that kind of
style of coding because it's kind of
nicely efficient but you know where that
is going
a code generation no seriously GitHub
co-pilot yeah I use it every day and it
really yeah it writes a lot of code for
me and usually it's slightly wrong but
it still saves me typing because all I
have to do is like change one word in a
line of text that otherwise it it
generated perfectly and like how many
times are you looking for like oh what
was I doing this morning I was looking
for a begin marker and I was looking for
an end marker and so begin is
blah blah blah search for begin this is
the begin token and then the next line I
type e and it it completes the whole
line with end instead of begin that's a
very simple example sometimes it it sort
of
if I name my function right it writes a
5 or 10 line function
and you know python enough to very
quickly then detect the issues so it
becomes a really good dance partner then
it doesn't save me a lot of thinking but
since I'm a poor typist I'm very much
appreciative of all the all the typing
it does for me
much better actually than the the
previous generation of suggestions that
are also still built in vs code
uh where when you hit like a DOT
it it tries to guess what the type is of
the variable to the left of the dot and
then it gives you a list a pop-down menu
of what the attributes of that object
are but copilot is much much smoother
than that well it's fascinating to hear
that you use GitHub copilot uh do you
think do you worry about the future of
that
um did the automatic code generation
the increasing amount of that kind of
capability our programmers
jobs threatened or is there still a
significant role for human our
programmers jobs threatened by the
existence of stack overflow
I don't think so it helps you take care
of the boring stuff and you shouldn't
try to use it to do something that you
have no way of understanding what you're
doing yet
a tool like that is always best when
the question you're asking is please
remind me of how I do this
which I
I could do I could look up how to do it
but right now I've forgotten whether the
method is called Foo or bar or how you
what the shape of the API is does it use
a builder object or a Constructor or a
factory or
uh something else and what are the
parameters it serves that role it's like
a great assistant
but the creative work of sort of
deciding what you want what you want the
code to do is is totally yours